لا هو مسمى قديم الحقيقه يعني
شعب نعم الشعب ولهذا نجد في اوائل الوثائق
واوائل المخطوطات لدي بعضها الحقيقه هو
عثرنا عليها يذكرون هؤلاء مثلا السعوديون
او في موقع اقدم شاهد في الدوله السعوديه
الاولى وجدنا هذه الكتابات ايضا المعارك
السائره ولهذا بدات ايضا تخرج هذه الجذور
الوحده الوطنيه لا حول هذا الاسم ينتقلوا
من مكان الى مكان فيشيرون الى رمزيه هذا
المكان بقياده هذه الاسره ال سعود
الشاهد هي مخطوطات قديمه في تحكي بعض
الوقائع التاريخيه زودتك
زودتني بالفعل بصور لمخطوطه في الدوله
السعوديه
سماه الطائفه السعوديه ولهذا تختلف عن
الكتابات المؤرخين الاجانب عندما يذكرون
تاريخنا فينسبون ايضا الامر الديني وهم
متاثرين
بينما هذا يقول السعوديه لان هؤلاء الغربي
الحروب الاوروبيه القديمه واللوثريه في
تلك الفتره فيحاول اسقاط ايضا الجانب
الديني لكل امر بينما لا ينظرون ايضا
مجتمع وطني قام على اسس ايضا امنيه في هذه
المنطقه